le lobbying est une question de prévoyance,
mais anticiper les mouvements de votre adversaire,
elle est votre ennemie maintenant et concevoir des
contre-mesures comment diable gère-t-elle
que vous êtes un travail
Elizabeth
j'ai été embauché pour gagner j'utilise toutes les
ressources que j'ai vous voulez quitter le
combat au pistolet  contrôlez il est plus de cinq
millions d'entre nous et nous sommes le
sergent armé Inquisition ils vous jetteront
en prison pour outrage au Congrès le
gagnant
a une longueur d'avance sur l'opposition nous devons le
rendre personnel vous savez le
mot anéantir cela signifie réduire à
néant
ce  est plus important que ma carrière mon
corps tu as franchi la ligne génie et
technique humble en droit il s'agit
de s'assurer que tu les surprends et qu'ils
ne te surprennent pas
[Musique]